the thing's hardest to bear
our sweetest to remember
we should not like sheep
follow the herd of creatures in front of
us
making our way where others go not where
we ought to go
silence is a lesson learned through
life's many sufferings
life is like a play
it's not the length but the Excellence
of the acting that matters
a gem cannot be polished without
friction nor a man perfected without
trials
life is very short and anxious for those
who forget the past neglect the present
and Fear the Future
life if well lived
is long enough
no evil propensity of the human heart is
so powerful
that it may not be subdued by discipline
enjoy present Pleasures in such a way as
not to injure future ones
until we have begun to go without them
we fail to realize how unnecessary many
things are
we've been using them not because we
needed them
but because we had them
a man who suffers before it is necessary
suffers more than is necessary
if you live in harmony with nature you
will never be poor
if you live according to what others
think
you will never be rich
wealth is the slave of a wise man
the master of a fool
to be everywhere is to be nowhere
what really ruins our character is the
fact that none of us looks back over his
life
anger if not restrained is frequently
more hurtful to us than the injury that
provokes it
only time can heal what reason cannot
to Bear trials with the Calm Mind Rob's
Misfortune of its strength and burden
our plans miscarry because they have no
aim
when a man does not know what Harbor he
is making for
no wind is the favorable wind
most powerful is he who has himself in
his own power
be wary of the man who urges an action
in which he himself incurs no risk
true happiness is to enjoy the present
without anxious dependence upon the
future
the mind that is anxious about the
future is miserable
the greatest remedy for anger
is delay
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
if you really want to escape the things
that harass you
what you're needing is not to be in a
different place
but to be a different person
time discovers truth
as long as you live keep learning how to
live
to be always fortunate and to pass
through life with a soul that has never
known sorrow
is to be ignorant of one half of nature
all cruelty Springs from weakness
the bravest sight in the world is to see
a great man struggling against adversity
while we are postponing life speeds by
we are more often frightened than hurt
and we suffer more from imagination than
from reality
it is a rough road that leads to the
heights of greatness
it is not the man who has too little
but the man who craves more that is poor
you act like Mortals in all that you
fear
and like Immortals and all that you
desire
sometimes even to live is an act of
Courage
it is the power of the mind to be
unconquerable
the life we receive is not short but we
make it so
we are not ill provided but use what we
have wastefully
begin at once to live and count each
separate day as a separate life
he who was Brave
is free
associate with people who are likely to
improve you
every new beginning comes from some
other Beginnings end
religion is regarded by the common
people as true
by the wise is false
and by rulers as useful
we learn not in school
but in life
nothing is more honorable than a
grateful heart
[Music]
to wish to be well is a part of becoming
well
he who has injured thee was either
stronger or weaker than thee
if weaker spare him
if stronger spare thyself
what can happen at any time can happen
today
the part of life we really live is small
for all the rest of existence is not
life but merely time
no man was ever Wise by chance
there is no enjoying the possession of
anything valuable unless one has someone
to share it with
you are lonely not because no one needs
you but because you care about who is
next to you
don't let yourself be controlled by
three things
people
money
or past experience
if we could be satisfied with anything
we should have been satisfied long ago
often a very old man has no other proof
of his long life than his age
of this one thing
make sure against your dying day that
your faults die before you do
the greatest blessings of mankind are
within us and within our reach
a wise man is content with his lot
whatever it may be
without wishing for what he has not
ignorance is the cause of fear
when a person spends all of his time in
foreign travel
he ends by having many acquaintances but
no friends